a soldier is
murdered murder and
Mayhem the makulu pack descends into
turmoil exiled Queens build their own
coalition
the reigning tyrants cherish the
atrocities of
[Applause]
war power is
fleeting the keys to the kingdom are
forged in
blood
mler has led the makulu pack well for
years but he no longer has the strength
for
battle
[Music]
there is one poised to take the
Reigns kidso the old man's
prote
but M hatler will never step aside
without a
[Music]
push
nobody wants
this Mah hatler knows it's
inevitable and
[Music]
concedes the alpha female has final
approval
[Music]
and just like that kitso is their new
leader he wears his scars with pride as
his star
Rises
his first task to lead the
pack against the hyena
Queen
the seasonal flood is at its
peak forcing everyone
together conflict is
inevitable di lady is learning to
navigate this dangerous
well
but it's a constant struggle keeping her
Cubs out of
trouble her eldest son sepo feels the
urge to
kill but he doesn't know how
or
who
[Music]
deol lady sees her son's
potential and they need to
eat but she's still
faster
stronger better
alone
you stay
here until I
call
yeah
now come
quickly
too
late mutti's minions are
everywhere thieves on the
take
oh
hunting for others is not energy well
spent they must keep
moving
exiled to the wat's
edge rarted on the western Pride are
rebuilding safe from the infested heart
of the Kingdom
but something is not
right
[Music]
mamut she must be sent a
message
such
insolence such
Vermin ramaha will shut them
down r Harter kills
[Music]
intruders send that message back to your
queen
he has too much at
stake this is not just a
home this is now a
nursery
the Queens have six
[Music]
cups five
females and one
male very good
odds this brood will more than double
their
forces females will be future Warriors
if rohara and his brother can keep them
[Music]
alive
mutzi and her Army now run
[Music]
unchecked growing arrogant and rich on
Limitless
spoils what have we
here
[Music]
A desperate mother and a very sick
baby
[Music]
how quickly The Merchant of death come
calling
they'd laugh at her
suffering
[Music]
it is only a matter of time and her son
is
[Music]
gone there will be no
sentiment
[Music]
the Commander's orders are
simple take what's
ours
[Music]
[Applause]
it does not matter who you are no one
can oppose a for L this
size not a grieving giant not
[Music]
anyone
kito's new rule brings peace to the
makulu
pack he is kind and allows their now
useless old General to
stay the new leader knows the importance
of
loyalty
[Music]
but now it's time for Kito to prove his
own
worth
The Hunt is his to
[Music]
lead
follow me and we shall
[Music]
feast
come
kitso brings them
[Music]
together the makulu pack is
back
United and
[Music]
strong and ready to take on
tyrants
mammutti moves unchallenged through the
kingdom defeating all who oppose
her
she wallows in her
success a brilliant and ruthless
General and she knows her real
weapon is
numbers their future domination will
take a different kind of
leadership mutzi and her sisters carry
the next generation of
[Music]
soldiers but they will all be
tested
even tyrants are born weak and
helpless and everyone in the Kingdom
will kill to bring them
down
[Music]
what up and his siblings relish their
Adventures but Deco lady does
not she will never be at peace until her
Cubs are
[Music]
grown she's pushed to her
limits in someone else's
stronghold
Ramo hared and his brother Patrol this
[Music]
border this is Western Pride
territory
a jealous King will not share with
[Music]
anyone the punishment for
trespassing is
death no matter who you
are
[Music]
deal lady draws the attention of the
Kings
the young mother sacrifices herself to
save her
CS
desperate cries are met with only
silence did I do
enough deal lady fears the
worst
[Music]
despite their youthful innocence her
Cubs knew exactly what to
[Music]
do
SEO and his siblings are finally
understanding how this Kingdom
works
kitsu is coming of age as head of the
makulu
[Music]
pack he's living the
dream it's time to forge a new Legacy
and add strength to the
pack
[Music]
but myut Scouts are still always on
their
tail no matter what kitso
does they just keep
coming
he must lead them somewhere
safe where his new Dynasty can
grow to become a force that will reckon
with the
scourge
the Western Pride holds court on the
fringes
but someone is not
happy rohar is no natural in the
nursery
the Cubs adore
him but he's not feeling very
adorable
[Music]
his Queens do their best to keep the
peace be careful little
ones
[Music]
a king needs his
space some alone time might do him
[Music]
good but with rohart
gone his family is
exposed
this is rotten Army s Central Command
hidden here in the heart of the
Kingdom the nursery is their inner
sanctum mammutti is a gifted
commander and devot voted
mother to a prince and
[Music]
princess her daughter is The Heir
Apparent next in line for the crown she
will want for
nothing she already shows the Evil
Genius of
leadership that's my
[Music]
girl the future is yours for the
taking it's in our our
blood diol lady's Cubs are growing
up so she can enjoy a r moment of
Peace SEO and his siblings explore every
dimension of their adopted
world
they've been pushed into the
swamp this much water makes the hunt
much
[Music]
harder
seo's instincts are
[Music]
strong but he still has much to
learn for now it's all up to de
lady
she's a masterful
[Music]
hunter but her Cubs did not
follow
and now they're stuck Stranded by Deep
[Music]
Water alone and
helpless de lady has no choice but to
give up her prize and return to
them another dinner
cancelled
the fa's lucky
day the family hasn't had a proper meal
in
days the Cubs need to keep
up and grow up
fast she needs their help to hunt
here they're running out of
time
when history Chronicles War few record a
tyrant's gentle
[Music]
aside but far from the front line these
are mud's most prized
[Music]
possessions
Natural Born Fighters but still so small
so
vulnerable many eyes guard the precious
[Music]
brood but it only takes a distracted
moment
the spoiled princess is
alone and
unguarded who's this
Beast a great fanged monster with
terrible
[Music]
tusks but there's no mistaking the
stench of
[Music]
evil
muty and the clan
return to find the princess
safe she was cautious and
wise soon she will be the one to be
feared
[Music]
with ramara and his brother away the
lionesses of the western Pride can
breathe some
relief no temperamental Kings to a
peace but in their
absence
the door is open to
[Music]
another a solitary
Nomad wants what rohara
[Music]
has to get it this Drifter would kill
the
Cubs but the Queens will not let that
happen
[Music]
they call the
shots
bow to
us and
leave is they're going to take the
kingdom the family must stay as
[Music]
one
loyal
United and strong females of the
ultimate
[Music]
power with five young
lionesses the Western Pride sets their
sights on the Savage
Kingdom
[Music]